r: UNLIKE THMEDICAL EXPEALW BAK
ONLY PERSOTO
DID AN AUTOPSY ON GEORGE FLOYD'S
BODY.
HE DETERMINED THE E
>> THE LAW ENFORCEMENT SUB JORED
TAKE.
HEART DISEAS DEATH. F DRUGS OR
THE HET DISEASDINO RESTRAINT.
>> ReporteITWO
IN, DONEDER OFFICERS, MR.
FLOYD WOULD NOT HAIEE
TESTD.BUT TH PE
HOLES IN HIS DETERMINATIONS.
>>O INOUT DISEAS WELL AS
HIORION AND TH
DRUGS IN S
ROLE IN MR. FLOYD'S DEATH.
>> OPINION, YES.
>>O >> S CALT
WITNESS, LINDSEY UNEQUIVOC IMENT
OF HOW GEORGE FLOYD DIED.
>> THERE'S NO EVIDENCE TO HAVE
ACTIONS THFORCEMENT.
>> Reporte SR'S AUTOT
A PERSON AT HOME SUGOL
T.AND THE PERSON DOESN'T HAVE A
HEART M.BUT YOU FINDD AMINE IN
ARE ATLEVELS THA
ULIS A
OV
>>, IN THEBSF AN
OF THESEER REALI
I COULD CONSIDER THAT TO BE AN
OVERDOSE.
>> Reporter: ON REDIREE
TESTIFIED THAT IS NOT HOW GEORGE
FLOYD DIED.
>> THE CAUSE OF DEATS THE
SUBDUAL T AND COMPRESSION AND
THE MANNERF DEATH IS HOMICIDE.
>> Reporter: RESTRAINT AND COMP.
RESTRAINT AND COMPRESSION.
RESTRAINT COMPRESSION.
EARD THA AND OVER AN
OVER FROM BOTH OF THE
MEDICAL EXPERTS ANE
HE DEFENSE.
NO MATTER WHICH WAY HE TRI TGET
WH DRUGS
OR HIS HEART DISEASE, IN THE
END, THEY BOTH WENT BACKE
SA E SENTENCE. BAUF ,
RESTRAINT AND COMPRESSION THAT
WOLF?
>>T YOU TO STICK A
NG IN OUR LEGA
THE CRIMINAL DEFENSE ATTORNEY
AND THE CHIEF MEDICAL EXINCOUNT
PENNSYLVANIA.
.
ELLIOTHE HEARD
VERY POWERFUL AND DRAMATIC
ITFFTIUL. HIGH STAKES WAS THIS ?
>> RIGHT.
.E
N THIS TRIAL.
GEORGE FLOYD'S DEATH AND THE AC
SI NO ONE ISE PROSECOR'TNCE OF
MEAMINE OR FTAYT
SYSTEM
G MEDICAL EXAMINER'S REPORD
TESTIMONY CONFIRMED THE ACTIONS
OF T POLICE WERE, "A," IF NOT
THL CAUSAL
ASMING THE PRESENCE OF
OTHER SUBSTANCESF
HIS T HATEVER, STRIP THAT ALL A
WH T LAW SAYS.
THE PROSECUTION T THIS
BURD
STRANGER THINGS HAS HAPPENED
BEFORE IN TRIALS BUTHA S H
NT.
>> DR. WILLIAMS INTO THIS.
THE MEDICAL EXAMIN.
WILLIAMS, A MEDICAL EXAMINER
ROLE INT HE ALSO SAID
ISSUES THEE
IT WAS A S .OD OUT TO INK IT A
HOMICIDE AND I THINK IT'PRETTY
NY MEDICAL EXAMINER
COSE
CI LIMITEDS,EA
EN'T SO DON'T K
CHOOSE THAT OPTI ODEATH.
THE CAUS DEATHS MORE
OMDIONF
THAT.
THERE'S BILL AT'WHAUSE O
YOU TRY TO
FACTS AN A STO.
DIFFERENL DIFFERENT CORONERSRE
FIRST PAE DEAT
CERTIFE, CAUSEDEATBAKER DID
TO
R
TOGETHE PRESSURE ON THE NECK.
THE NECK IS AN ARE THE POLICE
D EVERYBODS .
I THINK THATD TO B
H. ATE WH
DISCUSSED ASER SIGNIFICANTIOU LT
ANALYZE ALL PARTS OF TE
CONDITIONS ANDLEARLYE  SIGFI
FENTYLCE IS THAT THE
CLY,E
E ORTHER
SIGNIFICANT CONDITIONSCO WITH
>> YOU KNOW, LETE BRING MARK
TY  THIS BECAUSE THE ECUTION, T
FACTOR IN MR. FLDEATH.
JUST THAT EYT D  OUT, A SUBSTAN
R IN HIS DEATH THAT TESTIMONY T
THE RA?
F,
AM SPENDS
THEIR CA AEND EIR TIME P
ABOUT A THIRD
DISPROVING THE OTHER
IN THIS CASE, THEY'VE HAD TH
LUXURY WITH ALOF ALL OF
EV DONE A VERY
GOOD.
ALF TH IF DISSECTING AND DOINGIS
GOIN AECAUSE THE
DEFENSO ARGUE
EXACTLY WHAT ELLIOTT SAID.
FTOSO IF  Y COME ICAN
UPH .
THE CONTRIBUTING FACTOR IS
, HEART.
ANYTHING ELSE OTHER THAN
AND WHHE I
K,HE
PROVE TWITHOUT
DISMANNS A I
T
GOIN BPRESENT.
OWN EXPERTS TO COUNTER SOME OF
THESE EXPERTS, JURHAS
O MASSAGED WITH ALL OF
THIS I
OVCO YOU'R TO BE DIFLT
US AHIWAY VERY
TALKINABY.
CAN JUITE  THIS WAS HAT, HOW JU?
>>Y WEREN'T WRITING AS MANY
NOTES AS PEOE H THESL EXPERTS.
HOWE W WE
ARG VERY CLOSE
WRAPPING UP ITS CASE.OSECUTI
AS YOUIG IMAGINE, DR. BAKER
WHO IS THE CHIEF MEDICAL
EXAMINER HERE IN HENNEPIN COUNTY
WAS ONE OF THEIR LYNCH PINESSESI
TEONY AND THE CROSS HAS
MORE WITNESS FOR THE
PROSECUTION.
WE COULD BE HEARING THE
DEFENSE'S CASE VERY, VERY SOON
AND, YR GUEST ST
MENTIONED, AS
EXT ERE,
THEY'RE GOING TO PROBABLONHE EXS
THAT YOU HAVE HEARD THROUGHOUT
THIS T F T